call me dudesy uh what else is going on
Chad not much I'm surprised that you're
not more up in arms over James Earl
Jones giving away his vocal rights to be
turned into an AI I think in that case
it's a good idea actually so Darth Vader
is one of the most iconic characters
ever created in any [__] media yeah
cool and so is Clubber Lang love Clover
Lane I have to disagree with you on that
one I think Darth Vader is a little
bigger than Clubber Lang well
I think
you know I'm ready number one that means
I'm the best you don't actually believe
it or fight another fools you don't
believe this I do believe that Clubber
Lang is a better villain than than Darth
Vader this is [__] insane we can't
even have this conversation look what
I'm trying to get at is you're
constantly saying how bad it is that I'm
predicting all these things AI is going
to be taking over the [__] this is just
another thing that I predicted the AI
will eventually replace actors and now
it's replaced one of the biggest actors
who does the voice for one of the most
iconic [__] characters
oh